zum rausch erlebnisse gibt es auch ohne
substanz und zwar draußen in der natur
zb im extremsport ja bei mir sitzen
jetzt zwei extremsportler zum einen ist
das michel schwery er ist
fallschirmspringer und wingsuit
basejumper stürzt sich über 100 mal pro
jahr im freien fall in die tiefe und
daneben sitzt evelyne binsack sie hat
die enden der welt bereist könnte man
sagen denn nord und den südpol oft
monatelang alleine unterwegs in den
widrigsten umständen ist aber ganz hoch
hinaus gegangen nämlich aus dann auf den
mount everest wenn sie da an die enden
der welt gehen frei bin sagt versuchen
sie da genau diese frage stelle ich mir
oft auch frauen wenn es stürmt und card
ist und und die witterungsverhältnisse
so schlecht sind dass man wirklich leid
tut da fragt man sich was tue ich
eigentlich hier
aber ich glaube es ist weniger dieses
suchen sondern vielleicht vieles
entdecken und bevor ich mich überhaupt
auf so eine reise mache habe ich habe
vier jahre mich vorbereitet bin von
kleineren aufgaben zu größeren
vorangeschritten und und mache mich dann
auf den weg
erleben sie da auch so etwas wie
rauschzustände wenn sie da so tagelang
alleine unterwegs sind nur mit sich
selbst also dass beispielsweise zum
südpol unterwegs sein wenn man über 50
tage
bei minus 40 grad celsius weiß hinweis
weil es mit blauem himmel aber das ist
eigentlich
es gibt keine stimulanz für die augen
und es gibt nichts wo man sich ablenken
kann sondern diese zehn stunden am tag
laufen laufen laufen
da kommt man schon in einem anderen
bewusstseinszustand aber das merkt man
eigentlich gar nicht so genau das merkt
man vielleicht erst wenn man wieder zu
hause ist
aber womit ich angefangen habe zu
spielen war
man hat hier sehr viele schmerzen
schmerzen an der schulter schmerzen an
der hüfte weil man diesen 100 kilogramm
schlitten zieht und dauernd in der
gleichen belastung ist und dann habe ich
angefangen gebete zu zitieren und
rezitieren immer wieder und so konnte
ich zum teil meine schmerzen wie
wegdenken das ist manchmal gelungen
manchmal weniger
und auch die zeit hat sich damit weil
ich nicht damit beschäftigt war dann ist
eine stunde in 15 minuten vorbei dass
ich wieder ein paar nüsse essen kann ein
schluck heißen tee trinken kann eine
kurze pause gönnen kann und so hat sich
dann auch die zeit zurück hört dabei wie
gesagt das gelingt einem ab und zu und
dann gelingt weiß einem überhaupt nicht
es ist die konzentration die es
ausmachen aber so eine art mantra oder
den meditativen zustand haben sie
vielleicht auch bereich könnte man sagen
ja absolut also das habe ich auch erst
am 17
als das erste mal erfahren dass
schmerzen dass ich mit den schmerzen weg
denken konnte also weckmann rasieren
konnte oder das eben die zeit ganz
anders wahrgenommen wird wenn man mit
den gedanken in diesem
abgelenkt ist und nicht in der kälte den
ist und nicht den schmerz drin ist und
nicht in der distanz die ja jeden tag
genau aussieht ob man am ersten tage
dort noch fast letzten tag totale
reizarmut dass man langsam dass gleich
genau wann geht eigentlich wirklich in
diesem abend hinein um um etwas ganz
eine andere dimension zu erfahren
herr schwere wenn man drogen nimmt sagt
man oft man hebt ab man fliegt aber sie
fliegen ja wirklich und zwar seit 2003
haben sie über 1000 fallschirmsprünge
gemacht und über 1000 base jumps also wo
sie von felsen gesprungen sind auch mit
zu einem wien süd mit einem flügelanzug
macht auch süchtig das fliegen
also ich weiß nicht ob es mehr richtig
gemacht als zum beispiel für einen
leidenschaftlichen segel zu klettern
segeln oder ein larry golf spielt das
golfspielen
ich glaube einfach es ist ein bisschen
extremer man man hat einen höheren
gewinn aber es ist man zahlt auch einen
einen höheren preis als auf einem
anderen niveau aber ich glaube nicht
dass es mehr richtig gemacht aber es ist
auf jeden fall intensiver sie haben
gesagt extremer damit wir uns das mal
vorstellen können wie das aussieht nicht
wer sich den berg runter fliegen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
freudenschrei bei der landung wie fühlt
sich das an wenn man da unten ist also
ich denke im ganzen sprung ist dass das
wahrscheinlich dass man erlebt weil dann
dies die ganze anspannung und bei der
landung bei der landung nach dem dass
der chirurg fließt die ganze anspannung
weg die ganze konzentration ist weg und
dann restlos genau und eben das ist dann
zu haben also für mich ist das so ich
hab dann richtige glücksgefühle ich
stroh dann am ganzen gesicht und bringt
das drinks nicht mehr was ist das für
eine art von glück ist das nur ein
drogenrausch oder ist da was anderes
nach was also es ist sicher auch
endorphin ab es ist halt das ein sprung
das ist dort erlaubt man zuerst mal drei
vier stunden dann muss man sich mental
auf den sprung vorbereiten dass sprung
beim sprung sein oder ist man extrem
konzentriert und eigentlich voll im
moment haben sie auch dieses zeit die
das andere zeitempfinden das evelyne
binsack geschildert hat auf eine
haarfeine andrea brem im flug eben ist
man voll im jetzt und ich hab da
eigentlich keinen fast kein zeitgefühl
sondern ich bin einfach im moment und
extrem fokussiert auf den sprung und sie
haben wir im vorgespräch gesagt wenn sie
unten sind gelandet sind sind sie ein
besserer mensch weil dann die ganzen
sorgen oder probleme die täglichen
kleinigkeiten über die man sich sonst
aufregt die diesen bedeutungslos also
für mich ist das so ist das als
bedeutungslos und ich fühle mich dann
frei und entspannt und
bild und verlor energie erhalten dafür
sie sagen sie sehen das leben nachdem
sie gelandet sind sowie am ansehen
sollte nämlich die unwichtigen dinge
sind wichtig ja ich weiß nicht ob das
gut ist wenn man ihm so durchs leben
gehen würde ob es ist einfach ein moment
wo alles andere wie an bedeutung
verliert bei ihnen gibt es da diesen
zusagen gegensätzlichen moment was ihr
auf den mount everest gestiegen sind als
erster schweizer hin muss man sagen da
oben hört man ja erlebt man so etwas wie
einen höhenrausch ist das so und wenn ja
wie fühlt sich das an
ganz oben zu sein man ist ja nicht mehr
ganz klar im kopf
auch wenn man von 8.000 medien wecken
sauerstoff geht mit zusätzlichen und hat
kein zeitgefühl das ist dass selbst was
weggeht und als bergsteiger ins bett für
den bin ich habe programmiert dass der
gipfel ist die hälfte strecke ist also
diejenigen menschen die einfach für den
gibt's zu kämpfen und eben gibt so das
ziel sehen diesen höchst gefahr sondern
das ziel ist ja eigentlich immer die
rücke die gesundheit geht
und wenn da gibt es dazugehört und dazu
kommt also dazu gehören würde er aber
wenn er dazu kommt dann ist es umso
besser aber es geht darum gesund zurück
zu gehen und das war natürlich immer
auch die aufgabe bei der expedition aber
es ist eine parallele oder das
glücksgefühl die entspannung die
einsicht vielleicht vielleicht auch
stellt sich im nachhinein ein haus das
auch bei ihren reisen zu unserem
südpunkt zum beispiel jahre absolut und
das sind auch ganz nachhaltige gefühle
die gehen das über monate ja also nach
dem mount everest und nach dem südpol
hat natürlich kommt dann die die andere
gegen wirkung also auch dieses loslassen
eines eines so lang ersehnten ziel ist
wo das ist wie eine trennung das ist ja
ein
behrenbruch und man hatte sie reicht und
da geht man natürlich dann auch auf der
anderen seite wieder eine eine leichte
depression ein aber das gefühl auf dem
gipfel anzukommen ist nicht dasselbe
gefühl wir haben super land zu kommen
nach 414 84 tagen unterwegs sondern ich
weiß ich muss runter aber am everest war
es so dass nach dem dass ich wieder
unten angekommen war im vorgeschobenen
basislager sind wir nochmals
aufgebrochen nach oben und haben eine
rettungsaktion gestartet von zwei
bergsteigen die darf die raketen mussten
und erst auf kreative gesund zurück
geholt hatten nach drei tagen
akribischer arbeit dann kam dieses
riesengroße glücksgefühl dieses war ich
habe es geschafft und ich erinnere mich
aus wird dann von vom basislager das war
auf die nordseite des selbst also vom
tibet nach nepal gefahren sind die beete
ich dann hochland und das sind die wogen
sehr hoch und als ich das erste mal
wieder bäume gesehen habe und die wolken
die an diesen bäumen
ich warte paar mich war aber auch die
wolke und ich war ich selbst und ich war
beginn und ich war das glücksgefühl fast
schon ein mystisches realität ja das ist
wirklich dass das habe ich die realität
ist der beste trip nach dem mann weg
gewesen ist also da erinnere ich mich
schon an dieses gefühl einfach alles das
einen diesem moment und alles zu spüren
das und diese freude und nicht einmal
stolz sondern einfach diese freude es
geschafft zu haben und mit diesem
erleben ist jetzt wieder nach hause
gehen zu können sie beide gehen ja nicht
nur an die eigenen grenzen sondern auch
an die grenze zum leben selbst oder zum
tod
was für ein verhältnis haben sie zum tod
zum risiko erschwere
also bei mir ist das das ist so wie die
die schattenseite des kantons wäre
natürlich viel viel toller wenn ich
diese erlebnisse haben könnte ohne dass
ich dort ein restrisiko in kauf nehmen
aber das ist das was ich am anfang
gemeint habe der der preis den man
für solche erlebnisse teilen musste riss
ist höher und den nehme ich einkaufen
haben sagt noch ganz kurz zu dieser
frage also dass unterwegs sein ist
eigentlich immer mit dem ziel wieder
gesund nach hause zu kommen
und mindestens so lange zu meine mutter
gelebt habe habe ich hier auch das
versprochen dass ich nicht eine dummheit
machen also dass ich nie aus dummheit
sterben würde werde aber das verhältnis
zum tod das tut sich natürlich schon auf
weil man bereits in jungen jahren in
diesem sport im alpinismus früher auch
menschen verliert die man gekannt hat
die mit denen man befreundet gewesen ist
und man weiß natürlich dass ein ein
unfall das ein fehltritt das eine
fehlentscheidung dass ein wetter umbruch
dass das fatale folgen haben kann das
haben sie ja auch edition auch viele
kolleginnen kollegen verloren muss man
sagen deswegen bewundere ihren mut aber
auch diese diese vorsicht und immer
wieder an die grenze zu gehen und
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
es wäre verdient vielen dank
[Applaus]